you guys are definitely the true
believers you've survived all the way to
the end of Friday you stayed on beyond
the coffee break so appreciate your
being here my name is Daniel I'm from
the Australian National University I'm a
PhD candidate there I'm visiting the
u.s. for a year as part of the Fulbright
Program I'm a Fulbright postgraduate
scholar at Carnegie Mellon University
where I've been working with Nina Balkan
so this is joint work with her I'm going
to be presenting a talk about
performance guarantees for transferring
representations and the work that i'm
going to be showing you is the basis for
a poster at i clear coming up next month
as well 17 minutes or so girl just one
leg health even though we don't have
that that's right I'm not planning to go
all the way to 5pm don't worry right so
this is the kind of use case that we
might imagine we got mr. curious over
here who had some really great cat and
dog photo albums and he wants to build a
binary classifier and miss a light bulb
over here says well there's all these
really fancy neural network models on
the internet maybe you should try and
use them and mr. Carew says yeah but my
cats and dogs are really special i I'm
different to them and this is sort of
the question that we want to ask can you
learn something from one task and
transfer to the other and many other
speakers of sort of touch on this topic
throughout the week but I guess I'm
interested in can you say anything from
a con amore formal perspective about
when transferring a representation from
one task to another I helps you so this
is a sort of model that that we have in
my case so you're trying to learn some
function from input space X to an output
space Y and maybe you've got a scarcity
of labeled data if your target task so
on the other hand you have a source task
and you suspect that the two tasks
related in the following way you think
that there's some shared representation
RF mapping x2 some feature space is easy
that crosses the two tasks and then you
want to learn some specialized
classifier from Zita why that's separate
for each of the tasks this is pretty
empirically successful for a range of
applications
in natural language you might consider
this F function to be a word embedding
function typically you know you might be
able to use one of these embedding
functions with no further fine-tuning on
the target task in computer vision you
might have a pre cranny neural network
and then maybe you would be fine tuning
the weights on the target task so
there's kind of various possibilities
clearly this procedure doesn't always
work if you pick an arbitrary source and
target task it doesn't always work so
the question is can we say anything
about can we find some cases where it
does work so let's just introduce some
notation so capital F is a class of such
representations and capital G is a class
of such specialized classifiers and our
sort of default hypothesis class is
basically function composition G circle
F all the hypothesis that can can be
composed that way and in general we
would expect to have in our analysis
more source point than target points for
our analysis to be interesting ok so at
a high level this is where where we're
going to go on the left hand side you
can see our sort of base case which is
on the target task we're going to
consider all possible representations
capital F and hopefully there's a good
one little F somewhere in there but the
problem is if we've got a scarcity of
labeled data maybe we're looking at to
be a space of representations on the
other hand what we could do in the
center is we could maybe learn some F
hat estimated from a source task fix
that in stone and then hopefully it's
nearby some good little F representation
and then on the right hand side maybe
what we can do is one better than that
we find some neighborhood around the
little F hat which we call big f hat and
hopefully we can construct the
neighborhood such that maybe we get
superior generalization ability relative
to use in capital F but on the other
hand we've still got the good
representation little F hopefully
somewhere in our in our neighborhood
so we want to try and understand this
from a statistical learning theory
perspective so I guess some of the work
on like wait transferring your networks
it's focused on things like you know how
do you how do you initialize a non
convex optimization in a good place
that's not the kind of question that we
we're going to look out here it's more a
question of can you restrict your
hypothesis class in such a way that you
get improved utilization on the target
task okay so the first case we're going
to consider is the following we're going
to learn some hypothesis on the source
task and we're going to try and extract
the representation function that we
learned and while in general we might
not be able to extract this if you think
about the kind of case of a neural
network if you know the weights of the
networks and maybe you can extract this
representation function that you've
estimated and then what we want to do is
fix that and then we're just going to
conduct empirical risk minimization on T
over this smaller hypothesis class which
is all the specialized classifiers
composed with this fixed representation
and we're going to do this empirical
risk minimization and now we'd like to
understand can we upper bound the risk
of the hypothesis that we that we learn
out of this for the target task in terms
of the source task empirical error so
we're trying to get some sort of
generalization error bound that moves
between source and target tasks we get
this result I'm just going to step
through it too suppose you've got some
transferability function omega this is
going to be quite abstract at this point
but i'm going to give you an example
where it is a little bit less abstract
in a moment and suppose that you've got
this following our transferability
property which basically says if I do
well with this representation little F
hat on the source task then that gives
me some sort of guarantee about how well
I could possibly do with that on the
target task and that's quantified
through some transferability function
Omega okay well if if I've got that nice
property which doesn't hold in general
but but if I have it then I can make
some remark about the generalization
performance on the target task
and what does this depend on well it
depends on the source task error the
empirical error hopefully that's that's
small this basically says how old is my
source task hypothesis generalized over
my full class hypothesis class capital H
and hopefully this term will be small if
my sauce task has a lot of training
example so ms is large so hopefully then
also my transferability function doesn't
grow too quickly so hopefully it's like
linear in its argument so all this time
hopefully you're small and then I just
have to generalize with my target task
training examples over a smaller
hypothesis class which is parametrized
by the VC dimension capital G so VC
dimension being basically a measure of
complexity of a hypothesis class so
hopefully what we're able to do is say
we've restricted our hypothesis class
such that on the target task where we
don't have as many examples we're
working with a small hypothesis class on
the source task where we have a lot of
examples we're able to generalize better
so hopefully we then get a better
generalization error bound than we would
have been able to from from am from
learning on the target task alone ok now
can we try and make this a little bit
more concrete an example yeah so we will
do the target asset we optimize the
bullet to us immediately ok right so
it's so so in this in this case no you
fix on the target RC fix the
representation that you learn and and
we'll consider another case where you
fine tune it in a moment so suppose
you're comparing these two scenarios so
on the target task you could either
learn a two-way a neural network from
scratch that's on the left-hand side or
maybe what you can do is learn it on the
source task and then fix the first layer
of weights don't touch them and only
optimize the second layer of weights on
the on the target task and in this case
then if we make certain assumptions
about it slightly simplified neural
network architecture and some
distributional assumptions about how the
source and target distributions are
white then we can say yeah we've got it
we're going to come up with a definition
of what this Omega is and I guess the
key intuition here is we want the source
task risk to reliably indicate the
usefulness of the representation little
F hat that we learn so well what we
don't want is we want some you know
weights on the source task and then
somehow that the badness of those
weights with respect to the target task
is like hidden from the source task
error we don't want them to be able to
hide anywhere so that the way that we do
that is make distributional assumptions
about the source task distribution and
also on the magnitude of the upper level
weights that we use in this example okay
I'm going to just sort of formalize that
this is basically specifying our neural
network function class we're going to
assume that there is some shared
representation that does exist so it's
sort of saying there there is some good
shared represent representation of find
if there's no possible existence of this
we're not going to get very far but then
the question becomes the little ass hat
that we estimated on the source task
whether that particular representation
is good we're going to make these
distributional assumptions it's
basically I create some sort of symmetry
between the source and target
distributions and if we do all of that
then we can say yep we can quantify what
this transferability function actually
is and so it's kind of a kind of an
example of trying to instantiate the
first urine yep circle as you hygiene
for a little Piper so sorry you get your
data you apply F to it that's you so
that's like a mapping from your input
space X to your feature space Izzy and
then G then you apply G yep so yeah
that's right s is the representation yep
you should read that as function
composition yep are using any particular
definition for what you mean by neural
network is it just densely connected
right so it's like a feed so it's like a
two-hour feed-forward neural network and
there's some restrictions about so in
fact it's quite a lunar class because
we've made a restriction on the
magnitude of the upper level wait a
minute
work as well which basically Creech this
kind of nowhere for the bad
representation to hide kind of condition
yeah is there actually a distinction
between having fixed representations
versus fine tuning them because couldn't
you kind of formulate the fine tuning
inside of whatever Network you're
putting on your face representations I
mean right so so in this case with you
got if you're moving from basically it
you're optimizing two layers of weights
you're only optimizing one layer of
weights you're working with a different
hypothesis class now yeah okay um this
just Maps the kind of improved
generalization performance we get the
green line is this transfer transfer
learning setting okay um so there's
another situation where you could be
instead of fixing the representation you
only just look in a neighborhood the
problem is that that neighborhood might
have the same VC dimension as your
overall hypothesis class so what we and
then then our VC dimension based bounds
won't necessarily capture that reduction
in sample complexity okay so another
option would be to start considering
stochastic hypotheses and the reason we
want to do that is we can apply a pack
Bay's result which basically says the
generalization performance of a
stochastic hypothesis depends on how
close it is in terms of KL divergence
compared to a prior hypothesis and maybe
what we can do then is use our source
task to construct a prior and a
restricted stochastic hypothesis class
and then we can apply one of these pack
base bounds and we want to find one I
guess a subclass of representations it's
small enough in the sense that all our
KO divergences within that class becomes
small so we can upper bound them in
terms of some new transferability
function omega on the other hand we want
it to be large enough as a
representation class to still capture
some good representation there's no
point gaining a lot in terms of
generalization error and then on the
other hand
not actually having a sufficiently
expressive hypothesis class and then in
that scenario we can gain a different
generalization error bound this is
basically builds on a pack Bay's bound
and hopefully this term here all of this
term will be small if we weren't well on
the source task and basically it means
that then the generalization error on
the target task is going to be more
tightly bounded because we've more
tightly bounded the KL divergence
between the posterior and the prior for
any hypothesis that we learn again this
is rather abstract however I'm not going
to go through this example but there is
an analogous to our network example
where we can define essentially a
neighborhood around the weights that we
learned on the source task and we can
say I only look at weights that are
close to those weights that we learned
on the source task now instead of having
that hard constraint on the weight that
we're going to transfer across and
saying we're only going to walk in this
little neighborhood what we could do is
is soften this to a modified
regularization penalty and basically say
what penalized a target task for weights
are diverging from the source task and
in a deep neural network what you could
expect is that maybe that penalty will
differ for the different layers so maybe
if you know envision for example you
know we expect a low level way to be
very copper to be very close if they're
doing common tasks like edge detection
whereas if you've got higher level
concepts at the highways we don't
actually mind if those weights diverge
and so we might expect the parameter
that controls how much we penalize
divergence between source and target
task weights lambda 1 we might expect
that to be a decreasing function as we
go up through the layers of the neural
network we set up a task to try and test
test this out basically we took a
multi-class classification task one for
images and one for text and we sort of
made it into a binary classification
task just by grouping half of the
classes into the positive class half the
class
the negative class and then the target
task was similarly constructed except
that the that the disjunction of labels
that we use on the target task work were
different to those for the source task
and they overlapped in terms of a true
measure of gamma so basically if gammas
won the overlap in the classes between
the source and target task is identical
in the tasks are identical and what we
did in this in these cases is we had a
lot more sourced task training examples
compared to target task the results are
here basically on em missed the best
performing results were using that
regularization penalty that I just
showed you that's that's this line here
and then the other ones are a base case
where you're learning the target task
from scratch this is where we're just
transferring the low level weights in
the network and fixing them and then
this is where we're transferring the
entire network and doing no further
learning on the target task when gamma
is one you can see that just learning
the source task is the best because the
tasks are identical as you'd expect with
newsgroups that we found that the the
fine-tuning didn't do quite as well the
tasks are designed so that basically
there is a shared representation baked
into the tasks because they're dis
junctions based off the same shared
representation which is the correct
labeling think what happened on
newsgroups was that the low level
weights were starting to encode
disjunctions of newsgroups directly
because newsgroups can be encoded
through like a sparse weight vector in
in terms of like you don't need that
many different kinds of words to
characterize a newsgroup and so for that
reason I think the weights were a bit
less transferable in the newsgroups case
so in conclusion too I'll take a quick I
just finish up and i'll take a question
a second in conclusion it's a step
towards the theoretical foundation for
transferring representations both with
and without fine-tuning as you can see
you know the kind of restrictions we
make it that they're relatively
restrictive so this is definitely one of
these situations where is a lot going on
empirically you know and it's hard to
get it's hard to really prove exactly
why this is working in inner more
general case but this is the first step
thanks thanks your time and yeah I'm
happy to take take questions anything
exhibit up against lenders right so the
task is
you divide up the digits into two groups
so it's like 1357 a nine is will be like
the positive class and then like the
other digits the negative class but then
for the source and target task the
groupings are different yeah so the idea
would be like in your network hopefully
you can encode they are yours yet you
can encode the individual digits in the
lower level of weights and an upper
level of weights you could be encoding
dis junctions over those digits yeah
that was kind of the I that was what
that's what the network would ideally do
yeah yeah I feel I'm wondering have you
ever tried to sort through the effect
union with other recommendation that the
workers out right so I haven't directly
compared that and I guess yeah and that
would be interesting as well yeah so I
think there's two perspectives on
fine-tuning I was kind of looking at it
from as I said more of a generalization
learning theory perspective but I think
there's a whole other perspective which
is like more of an optimization
perspective which is like I'm not really
so worried about generalization I'm just
trying to like optimize some non convex
function better so I think that's sort
of two and there's been some researchers
looked at that this kind of like a
regularization effect and a and an
optimization affect their kind of like
two distinct effects of basically
transferring whites in neural networks
okay okay you know even with other guys
you should probably still work right if
you show in terms of a few initial if
you initialize the weights yeah yeah
because you know often if you don't do
revelation I think you stopped early
especially in transporting to do that
right so it's so exactly there though
there are other agree there are other
approaches to regularization that I
haven't explored here Emily okay feiven
reduce already stopped now you just
select thank you covered yeah yeah okay